la noche electoral del domingo en
francia marca el inicio de la carrera
para los comicios legislativos del 2 y
19 de junio que cuentan con varios
puntos excepcionales el primero la
definición de la composición de sus
cámaras con una extrema derecha muy
fuerte y el segundo una abstención
histórica la candidata de la agrupación
nacional marine le pen reconoció su
derrota en estados presidenciales pero a
su vez haciendo valer su más de 40% los
apoyos aseguró que los dirigentes
franceses y también los europeos no
pueden ignorar los resultados y los
desafíos así como la aspiración de un
gran cambio de penn se postuló como la
candidata ultra nacionalista de cara a
estas legislativas de junio saludamos
entonces a nuestro segundo invitado del
día
ls
mikel erramos el periodista y escritor
especializado en la extrema derecha
gracias mikel por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 también en
el estudio nos acompaña rosa pérez más
de euros a buenos días mikel buenos dias
de nuevo raúl mikel queríamos empezar
por una lectura de estos resultados que
recordemos supusieron una victoria para
emanuel macrón pero también a selene
como una fortaleza más grande que nunca
para la extrema derecha sin embargo
destaca destacamos que hubo más personas
que se abstuvieron más personas que
votaron también en blanco o en nulo que
no las que votaron a la extrema derecha
como lee estos resultados
efectivamente la habilidad que tiene una
vuelta
organización de izquierdas no como la
francia sumisa obtuvo unos muy buenos
resultados históricos también estuvo a
punto de llegar al elíseo y que
posiblemente esta abstención también se
explique por gran parte de este
electorado que no sólo lo vota
obviamente a la extrema derecha sino que
también rechaza las políticas
el presidente macro y hay que decir
también que en realidad la extrema
derecha carnada en este caso por marine
lepén hace tiempo ya que tiene una gran
influencia en la política francesa
incluso en candidatos de centro o
centroderecha como el propio manuel
macrón por esto el triunfo más allá de
los históricos resultados que ha sacado
la ultraderechista marine le pen es un
triunfo también por el relato es decir
varios candidatos
no sólo mal macrón sino anteriormente
también si irak y hollande y otros
candidatos asumieron gran parte de la
agenda de la extrema derecha al lenguaje
de la extrema derecha y jugaron también
en estas aguas donde la extrema derecha
es al final la que acaba sacando gran
beneficio como hemos podido ver a lo
largo del tiempo y también en lo que
comentaba en relación a esta dificultad
por parte de la izquierda de elegir
entre macro ni le pen queríamos pedirle
otra lectura y es que según el instituto
ipsos un 42 por ciento de los votantes
que eligieron a milán son en la primera
vuelta se decantaron por apoyar a macrón
en esta segunda un 10 7 % apoyo al open
mientras que el 41 restante se abstuvo o
votó en blanco o nulo como lee también
esta repartición de los votos de la
izquierda en esta segunda vuelta
pero yo me atrevería a decir que gran
parte de la gente que votó a misión no
apoyo a ninguno de los dos candidatos sí
que es verdad que hay un voto protesta
para que el epen no llega al elíseo que
es el voto que se ha concentrado el
macro y esta parte reducida del apoyo al
epen yo diría que vendría más del
descontento general no que por una
situación no solo a nivel francés sino
yo creo que es compartido en toda la
unión europea por estas fallidas
políticas que encargan gobiernos como el
de macrón son políticas pues bastante
digamos reduce que reducen la capacidad
adquisitiva de las clases populares que
afectan también a varios derechos y
libertades y que tienen también esa poca
simpatía por parte del votante
tradicional de izquierdas por lo tanto
yo creo que aquí el voto de la izquierda
ha sido una gran sorpresa más allá del
resultado que ha obtenido marine lepén
ahora a mikel también cómo llega la
extrema derecha a estas elecciones
legislativas de junio
se viene reforzada te ocupas que no hay
que olvidar que la extrema derecha
concretamente en francia pues le surgió
también un competidor por la derecha
marine lepén que fue erick zemmour que a
pesar de sus ínfimos resultados pues la
blanqueo un poquito que todavía la hizo
un poco más amable de cara al electorado
y también ha reforzado este espacio de
la extrema derecha cada vez más normal y
más aceptado dentro de lo que son las
democracias occidentales a pesar del
riesgo que supone no pues para derechos
y libertades de muchos de estos
colectivos yo creo que va a venir
reforzada pero va a ver reforzada
también por una fallida del proyecto
neoliberal que el propio señor macrón
pues encarnó y es de estas políticas
fallidas que hacen la precariedad que
provoca la precarización de las clases
populares y que no confían en el modelo
que propone macrón y que por lo tanto el
voto del epen ya no es un tanto un voto
y marcado carácter ultraderechista sino
más bien de protesta de rebeldía aunque
luego voten en contra de sus propios
intereses porque no hay que olvidar que
la extrema derecha a nivel global el
proyecto económico que defiende es
absolutamente neoliberal mikel y para
terminar más allá del cordón sanitario
en una jornada electoral
cómo se puede hacer para que la extrema
derecha no vuelva a llegar a una segunda
vuelta de aquí cinco años o para que
finalmente alcance la presidencia de
francia
antes hacer políticas valientes que
neutralicen aquellos espacios de
descontento aquellas precariedades de
las cuales la extrema derecha se
beneficia esto es pues evitar que estos
problemas estructurales propios de un
sistema basado en la desigualdad pues
creen esas
competencias absurdas entre trabajadores
no pues centrándose como intenta hacer
la extrema derecha en cuestiones de
origen nacional de religión de raza
etcétera no por lo tanto esto es lo que
aprovecha la extrema derecha cuando hay
esta precariedad y estos problemas
propios no de un sistema capitalista
pues la extrema derecha lo que hace es
aprovecharlas y señalar precisamente a
determinados colectivos como los
culpables de estas precariedad es y no
señalan al sistema repito la extrema
derecha es profundamente neoliberal es
un partido absolutamente que defiende a
las élites por lo tanto las clases
populares deben encontrar que las
políticas reales que hacen los
gobernantes solucionan sus problemas y
no va a comprar el producto que deben
dar en cualquiera que meta solucionarlo